[Music]  young people have helped drive social  movements around the world from  protesting the established order to  furthering new ideas youth are often on  the front lines of political and social  transformations hoping to make the world  a better place  reasons for youth participation and  movements vary compared to adults youth  often have larger social networks which  can serve as conduits for the  transmission of ideas and mobilization  young people are also more inclined to  be innovative in their use of media they  may adopt the latest technologies to  help spread their message and mission  also youth may have more time and  bandwidth than older generations giving  them a greater chance to take risks and  fight the status quo altogether reasons  such as these make youth participation  in social movements an incredibly  powerful element  [Music]